mr. Eastman and I have the pleasantest  time to present an Oscar for the Best  Foreign Language Film  yes me that's right my dove and they  chose me for this part because I've been  involved in a few foreign language film  and I got it because I'm speaking  foreign language right now the  nominations are  adilyn 31 Sweden the Battle of neretva  from Yugoslavia the brothers karamazov  Russia night with mode pause and Z from  Algeria you do the others thank you the  winner is Algeria for Zee  I've thanked to all technician all  artists and friends make this postcard  possible thank you everyone thanks also  especially our partners mr. Stromberg  emmastone lac de mr. - allah and also  the hola because the movie is censuring  very many country but with the disabled  you helpers thank you